2,500 years ago,
one man's spiritual,
Jenny was the beginning of one of the world's major religions.
Today,
boasts 376 million followers.
He is simply called the Buddha and he grew up the son of a king,
sheltered from the realities of human suffering.
When he finally learned the harsh truth,
he left his family and set off on a path to understand the life itself.
First as a monk and then as a teacher,
and this week biographics,
we take a look at the Buddha Siddhartha Gautama,
the founder of Buddhism,
was a man named Siddhartha Galton,
that he was the son of a chief tannins believe to be born in Lumbini Modern Dana
Paul in the sixth century BC.
His father,
so at her Donna translating to he who grows pure rice,
presided over a large clan and cools the shack yard in either a republic or an
oligarchy system of rule.
His mother was Queen Meyer of Sakyo,
who is said to have died shortly after his bath.
The infant was given the name Sid Arthur,
meaning he who achieves his aim when [inaudible] was still a baby.
Several Sears with the power of supernatural insight into the future predicted
he would either be a great spiritual leader,
military leader,
or a king.
Since it off his mother died.
He was brought up by his maternal aunts,
Maha [inaudible] potty,
his father hoping to steer Sid Arthur and the direction of the throne shielded
him from many religion of any kinds and sheltered him from seeing human hardship
and suffering.
As such,
he was raised in the lap of luxury and blissful ignorance,
sweat.
He knew nothing about aging disease or death.
Had the age of 16 is it office father arranged his marriage to his cousin.
Yeah,
I said Ira,
who was also a teenager.
She gave birth to rep who though some years later said,
Arthur said,
do you have remained living in the palace until the age of 29 and that was when
everything changed according to the story.
One day off that traveled outside of the palace gates and he was deeply
disturbed by the site of an old man.
His Cherry is here,
China or explaining just the Dothan.
There's all people grow old and die.
The death is an integral part of life.
This prompted Arthur secretly venture outside the palace on more and more trips.
When leaving,
it was said that the horses hooves well muffled by the gods,
so it was to prevent the guards from knowing if his departure outside the gates.
On these trips he encountered a sick man and they decay and Kolbes and a
homeless only man,
also known as an ascetic.
China told Sid Arthur that ascetics give up that material possessions and forego
physical pleasures.
Very higher spiritual purpose.
After witnessing the reality of human hardship and suffering,
said author had no interest in living at the palace.
He left his wife and child to discover the true meaning of life first by living
as a traveling bag or like the aesthetics that he saw on the streets.
Is it off of us?
Went to the city of Reggie,
got Har n's,
began begging on the streets in order to survive.
He was recognized dad by the king's men and he was offered the throne.
He rejected his promise to come back and visit it once he had attained
enlightenment.
Once he left the city,
he met her hermits.
Brahmins saints named Alara.
Kalama.
Kalama taught Sid Arthur a form of meditation known as the sphere of
nothingness,
said Arthur eventually became his teachers.
Equal Kalama offered him his place saying,
you are the same as I am now.
There is no difference between us.
Stay here and take my place and teach my students with me,
but it's an author.
He didn't stand in steady,
moved on to another teacher who darker Rammer pooter.
Once again,
he achieved high levels of meditative consciousness and was asked to succeed.
Has Teacher.
It's an author,
refused the offer once again and he moved on through the practice of meditation.
It's an Alpha realized eight state of perfect equanimity and awareness.
Auntie was on the path to enlightenment.
He also realized that living life as an extremely deprived beggars he had done.
It wasn't working.
It had been six years and he had eaten very little and fostered until he was
incredibly weak
off the starving himself for days.
Sit Off.
That famously accepted Milken rice pudding from a village girl named Sujata.
He was so amazed.
She thought he was a spirit,
that to grant her a wish.
So the author,
after having this meal decided against living the life of extreme self denial.
Since his spiritual goals,
when not being mad,
he instead of opposite to follow a path of balance known in Buddhism as the
Middle Way.
At this turning point is five followers believed he was giving up and they
abandoned him.
Soon after he began meditating under a fig tree and committed himself to staying
there until he had found enlightenment.
He meditated for six days and nights and reached enlightenment on the full moon.
Morning of May,
a week before he turned 35 at the time of his enlightenment,
he gained complete insight into the cause of suffering and the steps necessary
to eliminators.
He called these steps,
the four noble truths after his awakening,
the Buddha,
Matt to too much and brothers from the city of balco run modern day.
I've got a the brothers trapezes runs Baja.
Leeka offered the Buddha his first meal after enlightenments and they became his
first later cycles.
According to some tax.
It's each of these brothers gave her hair and they were in shrine at a temple in
Rangoon,
Burma.
Legend has it this initially,
but I was reluctant to spread his knowledge.
Do rather is this.
He was doubtful of whether the common people would understand his teachings,
but then the king of Gods,
Brahma convinced Buddha to teach and that was what he set out to do.
The Buddha travel to deer park in northern India where he set in motion what
Buddhists call the wheel of Dharma by delivering his first sermon to the five
companions who had abandoned him earlier together with him,
they formed the first five Buddhist monks.
All five attains nirvana or estate along the path to enlightenment.
Yes,
not full enlightenment.
They were known as the ones who are worthy or perfected people from the first
group of five.
It's steadily grew to 60 within the first few months,
and eventually the song,
how I reached more than 1000 people,
the sign code traveled through the sub continent expounding the Dharma.
This continued throughout the year except during the four months of the Vassar
rainy season when ascetics of all religions rarely traveled.
One reason was that it was more difficult to do say without causing harm to
animal life.
At this time of year,
the Sangha would retreat to monasteries,
public parks or forests where people would come to them.
The first was sauna was spent at Veranasi when the Sangha was formed.
After this,
the Buddha kept a promise to travel to Roger,
got the capital of Megalodon to visit king than Besara.
During this visit,
Sarah put her in Maui Gallia.
Yana were converted to a psyche.
One of the first five disciples.
After this,
they were to become the Buddhist to foremost followers.
The Buddha spent the next three seasons at Vella,
Vanna Bamboo Grove monastery,
and Roger [inaudible],
the capital of Magna Carta.
Upon hearing of his sons awakening,
so to Hannah,
sent over a period 10 delegations to ask him to return.
On the first nine occasions,
the delegates fail to deliver the message and instead joins the sang herds
become era.
Hence the tents.
Delegation led by color dye.
He a childhood friend of [inaudible] who also became an [inaudible] offense,
however,
delivered the message now two years after his awakening,
the Buddha agreed to return and it's made a two month journey by first to
capital of Vastu teaching of the Dahmer.
As he went,
I just returned the royal palace,
prepared a midday meal,
but the Sanger was making an alms rounds in capital Avastin hearing this,
that whoa.
Donna approached his son,
but her saying,
how's the warrior lineage of Muhammad Sata and not a single warrior has gone
seeking arms.
The Buddha is said to have replied that it's not the custom of your royal
lineage,
but it is the custom of my Buddha lineage.
Several thousands of Buddhas have gone by seeking arms.
Buddhist texts say that suited honor invited the Sangha.
I rented the palace for the meal,
followed by a Dharma talk.
After this,
he has said to have become a sought out partner during the visit.
Many members of the royal family join the Sangha,
the Buddhist cousins and Nada and a new radar became too if it's five chief
disciples at the age of seven his son Rahula also joins and became one of his 10
chief disciples.
His half brother,
Nanda also joined and became an error hands.
His wife reportedly became a nun throughout his life,
but it encourages students to question his teachings and confirmed them through
their own experience.
This non dogmatic attitude still characterizes Buddhism today.
Buddhism is the fourth largest religion in the world and it is also one of the
oldest established in the sixth century BC in Present Day Nepal,
India.
Unlike other religions,
Buddhists do not worship a god.
Instead,
they focus on spiritual developments with the end goal of becoming enlightened,
though not in the intellectual sense of the word in the Western world's
enlightenment is most often associated with the 18th century European
enlightenment period.
Movements characterized by a rational and scientific approach to politics,
religion,
and social and economic issues.
In Buddhism,
the simplest explanation of attaining enlightenment is when an individual finds
out the truth about life and experiences and awakening.
Where they are freed from the cycle of being reborn.
Central to Buddhism is the notion that to live is to suffer and everything is in
a constant state of change.
All Buddhists believe unless one has become enlightened,
they will be reincarnated again and to gain four principles that the Buddha came
to understand during his meditation under the Bodhi Tree,
these are the truth of suffering.
Ducati,
the truth of origin,
of suffering.
I'm a Daya the truth of cessation of suffering and they're a ta and the truth of
the path of cessation of suffering.
Maga suffering comes in many forms.
Three obvious kinds are suffering corresponding to the first three sides,
the Buddhist soreness,
first journey outside his palace,
old age,
sickness and death.
The Buddha,
the problem of suffering goes much deeper though life is not ideal if frequently
fails to live up to our expectations,
human beings,
all subjects to desires and cravings,
but even when we are able to satisfy these desires,
dissatisfaction is only temporary.
Pleasure does not last,
and if it does,
it becomes monotonous.
Even when we are not suffering from outward causes like illness or Bereavements,
we are unfulfilled or unsatisfied.
This is simply the truth of suffering.
The next [inaudible] truth is the origin of suffering,
not day to day troubles may seem to have easily identifiable causes.
First painted them and injuries.
Sadness from the loss of a loved one in the second of his noble truths though,
but a claimed to have found the cause of all suffering and it is much more
deeply rooted than our immediate worries.
The Buddha taught that the root of all suffering is desire.
Tanya,
this comes in three forms which he describes as the three roots of evil or the
three fires or the three poisons.
The three roots of evil are greed and desire.
Representatives in ours by a Rasta ignorance or delusion represented by a pig
and hatred and destructive urges represented by a snake.
The third noble truth is the cessation of suffering,
and I wrote her,
the Buddha taught that the way to extinguish desire,
which causes suffering is to liberate oneself from attachments.
This is the third noble truth,
the possibility of liberation.
The Buddha was a living example of that.
This is possible in the human lifetime.
Estrangement here means disenchantment or Buddhist things to no sense conditions
clearly as they are without becoming in Sean's head or misled by them.
Nirvana means extinguishing.
Attaining Nirvana.
Reaching enlightenment means extinguishing the three fires of greed,
delusion and hatred.
Someone who reaches Nirvana does not immediately disappear to a heavenly realm.
Nirvana is better understood as the state of minds that humans can reach.
It is a state of profound spiritual joy with our negative emotions and fears.
Someone who has attained enlightenment is filled with compassion for all living
things after death and enlightened person is liberated from the cycle of
rebirth,
but Buddhism gives him no definitely balances as to what happens next.
The Buddha discouraged his followers from asking too many questions about
Nirvana.
He wanted them to concentrate on the task at hand,
which was freeing themselves from the cycle of suffering,
asking questions.
It's like quibbling with the doctor.
He was trying to save your life.
The fourth noble truth is the path to the cessation of suffering Maga.
This final noble truth is the Buddhist prescription.
For the end of suffering.
This is a set of principles calls the eight fold path.
The eightfold path is also called the middle way.
It avoids both indulgence and Sverre asceticism,
either of which the Buddha found helpful in his search for enlightenment.
The age stages are not to be taken in order,
but rather support and reinforce each other.
At the age of 18 bitter announced that he would soon reach Perry,
nirvana,
Raleigh,
final deathless state,
and abandon his earthly body.
After this,
the Buddha ate his last meal,
which he had received as an offering from a blacksmith named couldn't dot
holding,
violently ill bitter instructed his attendance and Nada to convince Kunda the
meal eaten at his place had nothing to do with his passing and that his meal
would be a source of the greatest Maris as it providers.
The last meal for a Buddha,
the Buddha,
his teachings,
again to be codifying shortly after his death and continued to be followed one
way or another,
and with major discrepancies by at least 400 million people.
To this day,
there are numerous different schools and sects of Buddhism.
The two largest are Theravada Buddhism,
which is mostly popular in Sri Lanka,
Cambodia,
Thailand,
Laos and Burma,
mine,
Mark,
and then there is Mahayana Buddhism which is strongest in Tibet,
China,
Taiwan,
Japan,
Korea runs Mongolia,
but a sax do not typically look to preaching invert people,
but they do look to help people on the path to enlightenment.
If with a pure mind a person speaks or acts,
happiness follows them like I never departing shadow,
so I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe doesn't do what it used to on
Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right and as always,
thank you for watching.